[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a horror sci-fi film called
parasite part one spoilers ahead watch
out and take
[Music]
care the movie begins with mysterious
aliens called the parasites starting
their invasion of humans they infect
humans by entering their brains one such
parasite enters the brain of a
middle-aged man sleeping next to his
wife while another such parasite tries
to enter the brain of a high school
student named shinichi izumi however the
alien fails to bypass shinichi's
earphones and hence resorts to infecting
his right hand instead startled shinichi
screams and tries to get it out upon
hearing him screaming shinichi's mother
nobuko rushes to check up on her son she
checks his hand but doesn't find
anything wrong she calls it his
imagination and tells him to go back to
sleep by the next morning the alien in
the man's body eats his brain and takes
over his human consciousness it then
decapitates the man's wife and feeds on
it meanwhile shinichi surprisingly
retains his human consciousness possibly
due to the means of entry of the alien
that entered his body the alien seems to
have taken over shinichi's right hand
and makes him do things beyond his
control like randomly grabbing
shinichi's girlfriend satomi morano
extending the length of shinichi's right
hand to grab things and throwing a ball
into the basket from a distance without
even looking shinichi got a way better
deal than that guy who just killed his
wife puzzled and worried shinichi
confronts his right hand with a box
cutter knife forcing the alien to reveal
itself it turns out the alien can
shapeshift it transforms his right hand
into a snake frightening portion ichi
however unlike the other aliens who are
ruthless killers the alien that has
taken over shinichi's hand is more
friendly it reveals that it was supposed
to feed on shinichi's brain but failed
to do so because of his earphones now it
has permanently become a part of
shinichi's right hand and will live as
long as the boy lives with no other
choice shinichi befriends the parasite
and names him migi as migi learns about
the japanese language sword fighting
human anatomy archery the other alien
goes on a killing rampage while
returning from school migi senses the
presence of other brain-eating aliens
and drags shinichi to a nearby
restaurant they find the main door
closed so they sneak into the restaurant
through the back door to their horror
migi and shinichi witness the
brain-eating alien feeding on a human
the alien senses migi's presence and
happily welcomes it however the alien
soon realizes that migi hasn't killed
its human host the alien then starts
walking towards the boy with a lost in
his eyes for his brain
megi warns the alien to back off knowing
that if shinichi dies migi will die with
him however the alien reveals that
although two alien brains can't reside
in one human head migi can reside in the
alien host's hand the alien then
amputates its host's hand and asks migi
to move over so the alien could feed on
shinichi's brain however migi declines
and the two aliens fight each other migi
makes use of the sword fighting lessons
and decapitates the alien host's body
consequently killing the alien relieved
shinichi thanks migi for saving his life
however migi tells him that it killed
the alien only because the alien's
transferring proposal was risky so
preferred living in his hand it is
revealed that migi is able to survive in
its host's hand because of the nutrients
it is getting from shinichi's diet migi
tells him that it will protect him from
everything as long as shinichi keeps
eating that sweet mcdonald's meanwhile
detective hirama starts investigating
the murders he suspects that a
cannibalistic killer is on the loose
that's pretty far-fetched detective you
should probably be looking for aliens
the next day in school shinichi's
principle introduces a new teacher named
ryoko tamiya to shinichi's dismay migi
reveals that his new teacher has been
taken over by an alien they later
confront tamiya tamiya assures them that
she means no harm and invites them to
talk after school they later meet at an
aquatic zoo where tamiya introduces them
to two other aliens shimada hideo a high
school student and mr a a police officer
the aliens ask tamia why she brought
them to meet a human tamiya who seems
more reasonable compared to other aliens
reveals her interest in studying the
humans way of life she even had sex with
mr a for her research she reveals she is
now pregnant with a normal human baby
tamiya feels that they all need each
other to survive and find the purpose of
their life she is also concerned about
the killings being highly reported in
the media and is looking for ways to
feed on humans without creating a media
spectacle she asks migi and shinichi to
cooperate with them when shinichi and
migi decline her offer tamiya warns them
of dire consequences if they try to get
in their way she reminds them that
satomi and the entire school is at her
mercy back at home seeing shinichi so
distant of late his mother asks him if
he's okay she nudges him to open up but
shinichi only gets irritated and tells
her that he is not a child anymore and
doesn't have to tell his mother
everything besides he's having lots of
fun with his hand in his room these days
the next day while returning from school
migi and shinichi run into mr a migi
senses the alien's intention to kill and
asks shinichi to avoid him shinichi
heeds his advice and runs away but mr a
follows him into a secluded alley with
no other choice migi decides to finally
confront him and order him to back off
mr a warns them that he is not like
tamiya he reveals that he heard about
the parasite that megi murdered in a
restaurant he calls migi a dangerous
parasite who must be dealt with an
intense battle follows as migi and mr a
fight shinichi slowly moves closer to
the alien hiding a metal pipe in his
left hand when he gets close enough migi
gives him a green light and shinichi
impales mr a with the pipe as mr a
collapses on the ground a frightened
shinichi runs away shinichi is shaken
after killing a man but migi amused by
nature reminds him that the alien had
already killed the human when it took
over the host's body meanwhile while
returning home from the market
shinichi's mother notices the helpless
mr a in the alley she nervously inquires
if he is okay from a distance back at
home migi suspects that an alien is
approaching their home frightened
shinichi rushes to the kitchen and grabs
a knife the door opens and it is
revealed to be shinichi's mother nobuko
migi warns him that mr a has taken over
his mother's body but shinichi refuses
to believe it mr a has separated from
his old body and moved into shinichi's
mother's body however the mere
suggestion upsets shinichi and he
threatens to kill migi if it doesn't
stop talking nonsense however shinichi's
worst fear comes true and mr a speaks
through shinichi's mother confirming
migi's claims shinichi breaks into tears
and goes into denial he apologizes to
his mother for hiding the truth from her
and pleads with her to stop joking with
him disregarding his emotions mr a then
pierces shinichi's heart and mortally
injures him migi screams in disbelief as
shinichi collapses on the ground mr a
tells migi that it is over for both migi
and shinichi as mr a leaves migi enters
shinichi's body through the hole that mr
a left on his back two days pass by and
shinichi lays motionless in his home he
eventually gains consciousness and gets
up migi reveals that it used a piece of
itself to cover the hole in shinichi's
body and left a part of itself in his
heart that had been destroyed migi then
returned back to shinichi's right hand
it was an experiment but fortunately it
worked however shinichi is not so
excited about being alive after losing
his mother he tells migi that it should
have let him die and breaks into tears
after collecting himself shinichi heads
to his school to confront tamiya he asks
her about mr a but she refuses to
disclose his whereabouts angered
shinichi shoots a knife at her but she
effortlessly blocks his attack and
leaves meanwhile detective hirama finds
shinichi's fingerprints on the iron pipe
and restaurant still grieving shinichi
wanders around the city and comes across
a political rally migi determines that
the politician named takeshi hirokawa
addressing the crowd has been taken over
by an alien it speculates that the
aliens want to create a place where they
can eat humans they should look no
further than the church of scientology
later detective hirama drops by
shinichi's home he asks him about the
policeman's murder but shinichi denies
having any knowledge the next day satomi
introduces shinichi to shimada one of
the members of tamiya's network satomi
reveals shimada has just transferred to
their school she forces shinichi to
shake hands with the alien the alien
tries to squeeze shinichi's left hand
but to his astonishment shinichi
squeezes the alien's hand with equal
force migi speculates that the cell it
used to repair shinichi's heart might be
still alive inside him and is changing
shinichi's body to become stronger like
the alien bodies it is also having
perceptible effects on shinichi's
personality as a once shy and docile
shinichi keeps insisting on finding and
challenging mr a migi tells him that he
can't always be there to protect him
because he must sleep for four hours
each day and unlike humans migi can't
choose when to sleep and also can't be
woken up during those hours sounds like
me on a sunday after a lengthy
investigation the police determined that
the parasites are responsible for the
series of killings in the city they
learn that the parasites can be
identified by their hair when one pulls
out their hair the hair strand reacts by
curling the next day the principal
learns about tamiya's pregnancy and
forces her to take maternity leave migi
and shinichi are excited by the news but
she reminds them that shimada will
continue to keep an eye on them she
reveals that shimada is going to
perfectly fit in the school environment
because just like her shimada doesn't
consume human meat meanwhile shimada is
in the art room volunteering to be the
art model for satomi and her friends
while guiding shimada to find the right
pose satomi's friend pulls out his hair
to her horror the hair starts curling
the girl and her friends realize that
shimada is a parasite and start
panicking she tries to run away but
shimata drags her back in he then
proceeds towards the girls but satomi
hurls a bottle of paint remover into the
alien's mouth the chemical disfigures
the alien and makes him go out of
control satomi encourages the girls to
run but shimata stops them and starts
executing the girls migi senses
shimata's killing intent and rushes to
the art room to his horror he comes
across a trail of dead bodies of his
classmates causing him to have a panic
attack migi helps him calm down and they
continue looking for shimada they
eventually spot the alien proceeding to
kill satomi shinichi saves her and
confronts shimada but suddenly tamiya
appears from behind upset with shimada
for causing the mess tamiya scolds him
and throws a diy bomb towards him with
the bombs seconds away from exploding
shinichi quickly grabs an injured satomi
and jumps out of the building after the
explosion the police arrive and confront
the alien who has survived the blast
shinichi sends satomi to a hospital in
an ambulance before returning to finish
shimada shinichi shoots a metal rod from
another building and kills the alien for
good tamiya then appears and tells migi
and shinichi that she is going to
disappear for a while until she has her
baby before departing she hands shinichi
the location of the mr a possessed
nobuko shinichi finds mr a at the
address and secretly follows him onto a
bridge however migi suddenly tells him
that they must return as migi is feeling
sleepy shinichi can't believe his bad
luck migi gives him his good wishes and
transforms into a sword before falling
asleep mr a finally notices shinichi and
is stunned to learn that he is still
alive the alien then launches an attack
but is even more surprised by shinichi's
speed while dodging mr a's attacks
shinichi starts moving closer and closer
to the alien mr a plays a trick on
shinichi using his mother's voice little
did the alien know that kids usually
ignore their mom's voices mr a then
proceeds to kill a distracted shinichi
but nobuko overcomes the parasite's
consciousness and blocks its attack
shinichi uses the opportunity to kill
nobuko killing mr a with her over the
course of the next few days hirokawa
wins the mayor's election and promises
to deliver on his promises typical
politician meanwhile detective hirama is
approached by a special assault team or
s.a.t officer named yamagishi who makes
him sign a letter of confidentiality for
a project called human life protection
tamiya and hirokawa are seen talking to
a mysterious parasite named goto who
reveals that when he took over its human
host's body it was instructed to finish
mankind the movie then ends with
shinichi's visit to satomi at the
hospital where an unknown individual
records him talking with migi
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching